so i am just going to rip the band-aid
off i am here to tell all of
you my wonderful co-hosts and the
viewers at home that this is going to be
my last season
here at the view megan mccain is
stepping down as co-host of the view
i will be here through the end of july
to finish out the season with all of you
which i
am grateful for on thursday the 36 year
old conservative commentator
announced the news that she's leaving
the abc daytime talk show
after more than three years on the panel
this was not an easy decision
it took a lot of thought and counsel and
prayer
and talking to my family and my close
friends mccain who gave birth to her and
husband
ben dominic's daughter liberty in
september
noted that the pandemic and quarantining
in washington d.c
changed her outlook on a lot of things
kovid has changed the world for all of
us and it changed the way at least for
me the way i am looking at life the way
i'm living my life the way i want my
life to look like when i think about
where i want liberty to have her uh you
know first steps and her
first words i just have this really
wonderful life here
and she went on to praise her co-hosts
whoopi goldberg
joy behar sunny hostin and sarah haynes
it is a privilege to work alongside such
strong
brilliant intelligent incredible
broadcasters
like the four of you you are the most
talented women on all of television
hands down and it has been so incredible
to be able to do this with you
in fact the daughter of late senator
john mccain and his wife cindy
said she initially didn't want to join
the daytime talk show
but it was her dad who encouraged her to
do it he said that i could never give up
an opportunity to work on
such an iconic show and to work with
whoopi goldberg and
he was right it was one of the last
things he told me to do before he died
following mccain's announcement abc news
released a statement to e.t
about her departure quote for the past
four years megan mccain has brought her
fierce determination
and vast political knowledge and
experience to the view
she recently came to us with her
decision to depart the show at the end
of this season
a difficult choice that she made for her
and her family that we respect
and understand please welcome our new
co-host
megan mccain
mccain first joined the show in october
2017
after leaving fox news and has been an
outspoken conservative voice on a
primarily liberal panel
over the years mccain has found herself
in heated arguments with
several members of the panel including
goldberg
and behar i'm talking about i'm talking
about somebody absolutely treated me so
much when i was on maternity leave you
missed me so much you missed fighting
with me
i did not miss you but despite these
on-air disputes
mccain and behar opened up to e.t in
2019
about their relationship behind the
scenes and said
it's nothing but love what is the one
thing you want the public to know about
our relationship
that we like each other they keep
writing things about how we can't stand
each other it really hurts my feelings
it genuinely hurts my feelings because
our dressing rooms are next door to each
other and you and i
have the same emotional reactions to
things sometimes in different ways but
we're both upset
equally the equal amount of the same
things and i wish people would give us a
break
and in january 2020 mccain defended
goldberg during an appearance on watch
what happens live with andy cohen
i could not do this oh if she leaves i
go like whoopi is the anchor
of the show and my life there and she
always picks us up when we're down
so wow but if she's gone like she jumps
i jump like whoopi is
like the like i adore her and i need her
as the moderator
and while the view never seems to
disappoint when it comes to those
passionate conversations mccain told et
that's all part of the show's appeal
i think that's why people like the show
is they know it's not scripted and they
know it's not we're not being phony and
i'm not trying to placate to an audience
and later she shared what it's like
being the only conservative voice on the
panel
i try and just remind myself that i'm
representing 50 of the country
i'm representing a bunch of women even
though i only have one chair